al amanecer del viernes se escucharon
disparos en todo jartum no hay señal de
que los combates vayan a parar muchos
intentan huir de la capital en buses
repletos para los extranjeros que
quieren hacer lo mismo la situación se
complica por los intensos combates cerca
del aeropuerto de jartum Estados Unidos
envió tropas adicionales a su base de
yibutti y se preparan para una posible
evacuación
debido a la desafortunada e incierta
situación de seguridad en jartum y por
el nuevo cierre del aeropuerto no es
seguro emprender una evacuación
coordinada por el gobierno de Estados
Unidos de ciudadanos estadounidenses en
este momento
al igual que Estados Unidos Francia se
mantiene a la espera en yibuti el
miércoles por la noche envió tres
aviones a su base en la nación de África
Oriental Alemania fue más allá con tres
aviones militares que van camino al
propio Sudán listos para evacuar a
cientos de ciudadanos alemanes de ese
país sin embargo horas más tarde los
aviones estaban de vuelta a casa ya que
la situación se consideraba demasiado y
segura en tierra Japón y Corea del Sur
hicieron lo mismo ambos países
anunciaron el envío de aviones militares
para evacuar a sus ciudadanos a 15.000
kilómetros de la capital sudanesa el
ministro británico de asuntos exteriores
James cleveley acortó su viaje a Nueva
Zelanda para atender la situación el
funcionario trabaja planes de emergencia
de producirse una evacuación masiva como
ocurrió en Afganistán o yemen a muchos
les preocupa el futuro que dejan atrás
con el aeropuerto cerrado es casi
imposible el envío de ayuda humanitaria